what's a believe nation happy weekend
it's Evan I am thinking of launching a
new potential t-shirt and I need your
feedback
[Music]
so there's this great clip of Sylvester
Stallone talking about how to him no
means yes it's one of my favorite clips
of him in this whole world turns you on
challenge I really just I just love I
didn't love it you know I love being
told no it just means yes no to you yeah
what turned you off lack of enthusiasm
when he turns me off so I love the
message of perseverance and I thought I
want to turn that into a t-shirt for
myself to wear for you guys to wear and
I hired a designer to come up with a
bunch of different designs I think we
have ten different designs and I love to
know which one you guys like the best
I'm gonna link them up in the
description we're gonna show a quick
preview of them on the screen right now
they're appearing let me know which one
you guys like the best check out the
description and if there's other quotes
or entrepreneurs that you would love to
see turned into a t-shirt let me know I
think it's important you know the what
you wear is an expression of yourself
you know I have my believe clothing on
and I'm looking to expand and so your
feedback is highly appreciated thank you
guys for the love hope you have an
amazing weekend continue to believe and
whatever your one word is much love see
you soon